how does it feel guys to have your first
album completed after all these years of
being together as a band
feels great you know I never had felt
hippo or a groover more accomplished
you know goodness album and letting it
out into the world has been a dream come
true right yeah especially because I got
to do it with my most fabulous band
mates and friends oh wow we like really
banded as a band you know while we were
making this album we're like totally
closer than we've ever been Grandpa
all right
what was the best thing about being the
house band on TV is the Muppet Show and
what was the worst thing about having to
share the spotlight with the other
Muppets well you know I can tell you the
Muppet Show was a great gig for us you
know no denying though we weren't the
main attraction yeah for sure but we
were like totally happy you know to play
our music to support the amazing show
that Kermit was putting on indeed indeed
I mean the best part of our experience
at the Hollywood program was the edge
and occasionalizing we got playing
alongside some of the well the greatest
musicians of all time oh for sure like
Linda Ronstadt Elton John Diana Ross
Paul Simon you know that this goes on
and on and on and on yeah
how come you guys have never actually
recorded an album before now have you
been avoiding making an album or did you
just enjoy being on the road too much
yeah you know our bad
are bad things happen
each of you what is your favorite song
on the album and why
that's uh
[Music]
well I'm afraid uh I'm afraid you're
asking an impossible query yeah that's
really tough all the songs are like so
meaningful to us it's hard to pick one
yeah yeah you know how about just say
all of them well you know I do got one
here how am I gonna get there oh you
like that oh yeah yeah
we are one that's a good one yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah on our way is good
um
picked just one we couldn't do that
yes
how about you describe your sound as a
band an explosion of GrooVe a melodious
confection oh wow like totally amazing
and like really groovy
wow how about you soon
yeah yeah makes sense what what is the
best part of living by the motto of no
logic no rules and no plans is that a
motto you would recommend to everyone
should it only apply to certain people
our rules sometimes important no rules
you know the best part you know living
by that motto the life is better when
you don't have any plans tying it down
man for sure like I always say you have
to embrace a totally chill Vibe if you
really want to transcend you know yeah I
doubt we could recommend date this
lackadaisical lifestyle to anyone and
everyone but if you're inclined to rock
uh you might just find it makes
everything groovy really right what is
the key to getting the ultimate and
perfect level of chill and is there such
a thing as being too chill
don't ask us
that's some pretty incredible isn't it
always everything you guys say is always
incredible so
well has has doctor teeth always been
the natural leader of this band did
anyone else ever try to step into that
leadership role or has it always been
him oh well you know our group is ruled
by pure actocracy one mind one Melody
one man I don't like I always say we am
is RnB the Electric Mayhem yeah every
one of us is a crucial piece of that
puzzle ain't that right totally yeah
like we really couldn't do it without
each other right that's right
how challenging is it to make every
person in the world happy and how will
you know if you've succeeded well it's
like really hard but you know it's
totally worth it yeah my intention has
always been to put a smile on the face
of everyone on the planet kind of like
mine oh for sure and and we'll know
we've done it when there's like World
Peace you know
it should only take us another couple
more years yeah we're close yeah yeah
yeah
see your smile look see
he likes my teeth
yeah so what do you guys love most about
music
the way it makes my ears tingle and my
mind expandually
yeah the fact of every person on the
planet has some kind of music that they
dig you know they ain't anything else
like that oh yeah music like awakens
like a totally spiritual and Zen part of
our souls wow yeah music loud yeah
that's right yeah that's about animal
yeah well I love your music so thank you
very much thanks thank you so much so
much thank you Christina lovely to speak
with you